hey everybody its Charlie so this is
gonna be my flash rebirth number one
video I think we got some teasers for
godspeed so just careful for spoilers
from that issue if you haven't seen it
yet I'll make some speculation based on
that but I think it's gonna take a few
more issues before we find out what's
going on with the villain so if you
haven't read it d.c rebirth kind of
tease up what the macro arc is going to
be for the rebirth event what's going on
with the missing 10 years is basically
saying the new 52 was like a period of
time that was stolen from them because
someone was playing God just running
some sort of grand cosmic experiment so
spoiler warning for that too I'm gonna
explain it real quick here we go
so dr. Manhattan or one dr. Manhattan
amongst the many in the multiverse is
said to have been the one to experiment
by taking hope out of the DC universe to
see what would happen with the
characters just is like a curious
experiment as a side effect of all this
the pre-new 52 Wally West the red-haired
yellow suit wearing former Kid Flash
Wally West manifests directly out of the
Speed Force and he comes back he's been
gone this whole time in the new 52 the
new version like the new 52 version of
Wally West was an african-american they
changed the character's backstory so
this first issue of the flash kind of
explains what's going on with all those
characters because they're all still
around they didn't get rid of the new 52
Wally West
there are now two Wally West's so the
one that came back the classic version
of Wally West is now in the teen titans
comic book so if you want more of him
you have to read Teen Titans he has a
new flash suit it looks red it's
actually pretty cool but new 52 Wally
West is now irises nephew this is what
iris looks like she and barrier just
dating they're not married or anything
like that but he stays with her at Wally
is staying with her she's kind of like
his caregiver slash Guardian but Wally's
like this precocious really smart young
kid kind of like on the flash TV show so
the title of the comic is deus ex
machina in god from the machine so that
makes you think of godspeed the new
flash villain of this event but we
haven't seen him yet so as is
appropriate
iris West is kind of like Barry's
conscience she delivers the big idea of
this issue you know we're in Barry tries
to do too many things so things slip
through the cracks he misses details so
then we learn about some of the
secondary characters about how Barry
wants a sidekick then he has this news
cake on the police force so you can kind
of see where this is going with God
speed him really wanting a Wally West
typed sidekick again but Wally being too
old for that he's often Teen Titans now
Barry Allen has a new assistant on the
police force but the flash still doesn't
have an assistant and his partner and
the police force is struck by the Speed
Force and infused with powers and you
see him moving here in the background
taking this criminal down that had been
trying to kill him who looks very much
like the colors that God speed is
wearing in the previous kind of tee up
issue for this so already you're like
okay this guy is very clearly going to
be turning into God speed he'll be like
the new flash partner that Barry wants
and he'll try to train him something
will go sideways and he'll turn into a
villain we really don't know a lot about
this new partner yet only that he goes
all the way back to when Barry
originally got his powers from the Speed
Force he was working a case trying to
help this person solve his brother's
murder fair you know big surprise that
sounds exactly like him trying to solve
his mother's murder so you can kind of
see he's like a mirror of Barry but it
didn't end up working out he got struck
by the Speed Force became the flash went
on all these adventures but then we find
here later that this assistant looks
like he might be harboring some
deep-seated resentment even though he
looks like he really does want to work
with Barry but we've only really seen
him for one issue but you can see how
that kind of backstory plays like a
villains backstory someone who wants to
do good to make something right I'm
gonna go back and save my brother I'm
gonna kill all these people that did him
wrong we actually learned that the
criminal that was trying to kill Barry's
partner when he was struck by the Speed
Force is called black hole he's part of
this organization in the partner
suddenly has this realization before he
gets struck by the Speed Force before he
thinks he's gonna die oh my god that
symbol was at my brother's crime scene
so then you go back to like this preview
issue of flash rebirth and you're like
wait a minute when he's saying I'm going
to kill them all maybe he's talking
about the villains so god speed isn't
going to try and kill all the Flash's
friends he's gonna try and kill all the
bad guys but that's still bad because
Barry's like well you can't go out and
just kill anybody you want great power
great responsibility so you guys let me
know in the comments just you know based
on those backstory bits do you think
that Barry's new police force partnered
with this really tragic backstory about
what happened to his brother with this
black hole criminal organization
do you think that this is going to lead
to him becoming godspeed because thus
far we haven't seen any other speedsters
that look like they fit the bill and
they usually introduce big villains like
this up front but really I feel like the
best evidence that we're meeting
Godspeed without knowing that it's God
speed in this issue is that the title is
called deus ex machina and god from the
machine so new partner granted godlike
powers starts to go a little bit nuts
with power but I'm really excited to see
how his powers are a little bit
different from the flashes his costume
looks freaking badass and I know a lot
of you guys want to see them use him on
the flash TV show I don't think that's
gonna happen just because the TV show
doesn't really follow the comics that
closely but it's totally possible really
anything's up for grabs when it comes to
the TV show the good thing about the
flash TV show is that it's not bumping
up against any of the movies like unless
it wanted to do the New Gods like I
can't do Darkseid because the movies are
doing Darkseid but they can do pretty
much anybody from the flash comics but
remember I try to mention this every
once in a while but when they do a big
bill in on the flash TV show they tend
to combine a couple of different
characters from the comics and then give
them a comic-book name but if you guys
haven't started reading it flash rebirth
is a lot of fun you don't have to read
it to understand what's going on in DC
rebirth and I will do videos for all
that stuff and I'm doing a little bit of
Green Arrow rebirth too so if you guys
haven't had a chance just check out some
of the rebirth comics and I actually
almost forgot I remember the flash TV
show Jesse quick is confirmed to be
coming back but I think we all felt like
she was coming back she said she was
such a fun character in the actress felt
like she did such a good job
did it make sense that they would try to
use her again but I have no idea if
she's gonna have powers flashpoint
throws everything up into the air but I
think they'll tease that out a little
bit I do think that she and Wally will
eventually get some form of powers even
if it's not exactly like the comics so
because it's VidCon and it's a new flash
video I'll say a new round of the
giveaway starts now it's just a $20
Amazon gift card all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video I'll announce the
winner when I post my next DC video and
there will be a separate new Game of
Thrones giveaway going on tomorrow
because they'll be Game of Thrones
finale stuff happening all Sunday so get
hype if you guys do see me walking
around VidCon feel free to say hi while
you guys wait for my next video to post
if you haven't seen it you can click up
here at the top sorry one of my hands is
holding the microphone you can click up
here
up at the top to learn all about
flashpoint season 3 stuff and you can
click down here at the bottom for the
Game of Thrones finale trailer coming
tomorrow lots of Game of Thrones
tomorrow so thank you so much for
watching
phantom high fives I'll see you guys
today
you